So, here I have a directory on my local machine,
which contains a couple of files, and I want to
put one of them into hdfs. All of the commands
which interact with the Hadoop file system start with Hadoop
FS. So first of all, let's see what we have
in hdfs to start with. I do that by saying
hadoop fs minus ls. That gives me a listing of
what's in my home directory on the Hadoop cluster. Because
I'm logged in to the local machine as a user called training, my home directory
in hdfs is /user/training. And as you can see, there's nothing there. So
now, let's upload our purchases.txt file. We do that
with hadoop fs minus put purchases.txt. Hadoop fs minus put
takes a local file and places it into hdfs. Since I'm not specifying
a destination filename, it'll be uploaded with the same
filename. So, it takes a few seconds to upload. And
now I can do another hadoop fs minus ls, and
we can see that that file is now in hdfs.
I can take a look at the last few
lines of the file by saying, hadoop fs minus tail,
and then the filename, and that just displays the last
few lines on the screen for me. There's also a
hadoop fs minus cat, which will display the
entire contents of the file and we'll use that
later. There are plenty of other hadoop fs commands
and as you'll probably have started to realize, they
closely mirror standard UNIX file system commands. So, if I want to rename the
file, for example, I can say hadoop fs minus mv, which moves
purchases.txt, in this case, to newname.txt. If I want
to delete a file, hadoop fs minus rm will remove that file for me. So,
let's get rid of newname.txt from hdfs. I create a directory in hdfs by
saying hadoop fs minus mkdir and then
the directory name, and now let's upload purchases.txt
and place it in the myinput directory so that it's ready for processing by hdfs.
Once I've done that, hadoop fs minus ls myinput will show me
the contents of that directory. And just as I expected, there's the file.